Hello Freak bitches,
that's the problem in psychiatry is there are no real biological markers.
They're trying to use a radiographic studies like Spec Scans,
Mris,
pet scans and what have you as rationale for starting people on medication,
but there's absolutely,
you know,
in the biomarker,
the biomarker panel that we have,
this is a direct correlation between someone having had a head trauma regardless
of it was Mildura blast trauma like Andrew had or a slip and fall or someone
coming up and hitting you behind the head or mma or boxers or mou type and
there's absolutely zero that they use to regulate what they're doing.
It says,
okay,
today's Thursday,
let's try this drug or this is Friday or else this month we're giving you this
Satchel of meds.
As many of the vets have come up and told me,
depending upon the day of the week dictated what groupings of medications they
were given and so what,
but let's break it down for people.
What do you feel is the underlying cause of all this?
It's related to Tbi.
Okay,
great question,
and the answer is number one,
from the head trauma,
it elicits chemical changes in the brain that we call inflammation and this
inflammation leads to disruption of chemical processes.
It's like,
you know,
the old alkaline batteries or the car batteries where we used to put distilled
water into it.
Well,
if you put coca cola in it,
it totally changes the ability of electrons to be conducted just like in the
brain.
So the chemistry of the brain is altered by the inflammation and it starts
shutting down systems so that the nerves in left side of the brain can talk to
the right side or the frontal lobe of the brain can talk to the temporal lobe of
the brain.
So you have disruption of executive function,
which is your ability to make correct decisions about things right and wrong.
Why do we have over a million veterans incarcerated?
That's because they can't make the right correct decisions about how to respond
to an innocuous,
uh,
you know,
approached by an individual that they don't know and they respond by assault or
physical or anger or the yelling at people.
And that leads them into jail or into incarceration.
So anyway,
the inflammation leads to hormonal deficiencies in the brain.
And what we found is that there's,
since 1986,
Dr Lou at a Paris found that we have enzyme systems that take cholesterol and
converted into hormones that actuate and regulate our brain function from
schizophrenia to als to Parkinson's disease to bipolar,
to all the different disorders.
There was a recent article that I sent out to our journal Group and Andrew's in
it,
and it was about management of neuroinflammation,
brain inflammation to treat psychiatric diseases.
In the past six months,
we've been starting to see a lot of articles talking specifically about
inflammation,
creating all these things that we're trying to treat with medications that are
ineffective.
Uh,
last month,
uh,
had a class in
Arizona and I presented a group of articles and one of the key articles was the
fact that they found people with a typical depression that's depression that
doesn't respond to traditional medication.
So you're on whole bunch of 13 medications and you still depressed.
So they found in 61 percent of these people who were still depressed with
atypical depression that they had growth hormone deficiency and then when they
replaced the growth hormone within one to two months,
their depression disappeared and they had some beneficial side effects.
They slept better,
they had more mental energy,
they were socially more adaptable and they're reactive scores that creates an
assault situation.
They were calm.
Someone said boo to them and they said,
Oh,
who do you as opposed to getting into their face.
So it's a very clear and it's becoming clearer and clearer in the literature
around the world.
Now we've been doing this since 2004 and the inflammation is really the problem.
So unfortunately there is no specific medication.
They talk about use of aspirin and Ibuprofen in things like Alzheimer's disease,
which is an inflammatory disease.
I know I shared it with you in the past that if a football player has one major
concussion on the field,
he's 19 times at greater risk of developing Alzheimer's between 30 and 49 years
of age because it's an inflammatory illness.
It's not genetics by itself.
There are people with genetic predisposition to it because they generate this
thing called Beta amyloid,
but trauma,
any kind of trauma to the head can elicit increased production of Beta amyloid
and lead to these problems.
I get.
I get heavy.
You know I'm going to talk about life and death.
You got talk about life now.
That is what we're doing.
We're living in some people who are dying.
That's life and death.
We're all.
What's really interesting is that we're all going to die.
Yes.
And add that everybody pushes away and I guess that's normal to push away,
you know,
thoughts of your death,
but the real enlightened,
like the Buddhist,
Buddhist,
eastern,
eastern and stuff,
they say the way to get enlightened is to die.
If you can check this out,
is to die before you die.
Meaning lately kind of go into the fear and they claim that the fear is
releasing ego,
which what they mean by ego is like,
like you have this beautiful studio when you have a career and a wife and a kid.
Kids,
I guess.
And,
and it's like letting.
It's like you can't be attached to it,
you have to die to that.
Like in other words,
you don't own your wife,
you don't own,
um,
anything really because we're just,
we're.
The bottom line of it is,
is we are temporary.
Yes and empowerment it.
And it doesn't mean you can't enjoy,
you know,
like you're in the prime of your life,
right?
So why think about your fucking death,
you know what I mean?
And
then the incredible institutional entrenchment that happens when you adopt a
certain view,
right?
And then it's so hard to reverse out of that particular chosen line of thinking,
it becomes almost impossible.
You know,
this institutions are not built for that.
They're not really built for science.
You know,
science is supposed to be,
as I said earlier,
self-doubting self questioning.
You have new observations,
so you change your course.
That's what science is supposed to be like you,
you test things and they don't work out.
And then you move on to another idea.
But an institution is,
is it's almost like institutional sciences click an oxymoron because an
institution is meant to not flip flop on their publics.
Not to change their views,
not to lose,
not to allow people to lose faith in them.
So it's,
it's there,
it's,
it's the wrong kind of body to do science.
Um,
so it's made me much more,
a much more cautious about how much I want our government to do,
um,
because if I had just turned over this one little leaf and found this huge
disastrous program,
uh,
you know,
I just wonder if I'd turned over any other leaf.
What,
uh,
what,
what else would I find?
I think you'd find similar in competence probably.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so it's changed my political thinking quite a bit.
Um,
and then I think it's also,
you know,
when I see the way that the scientific debate is played out and I,
and you know,
I know the science so intimately now,
um,
you know,
I know I've read every single nutrition experiment that has really been done
since the mid fifties.
And,
you know,
when I see the way the debate plays out in public,
I see that a American heart association,
Presidential Advisory,
which I just see as a,
you know,
it's not honest science or our last dietary guidelines,
expert committee in their report saying,
you know,
we should,
we should all eat a plant based diet.
And I,
you know,
I can see how bad that science is.
And so,
you know,
I see that,
that I can see now so much better the,
the,
the way that PR firms spin messages and the way those messages are echoed all
over and the way,
you know,
it's just the way it's what's happening in our politics.
It's,
it's happening in our science.
Um,
and,
and so I think it makes me somewhat despair about our ability to have good
science rise to the top because you knew when you have institutions like Harvard
and tufts,
you,
all of our top institutions are so deeply invested in this wrong hypothesis.
Yet I don't even know.
I don't know where people should turn to,
to,
you know,
how,
how do we sort ourselves out of this mess?
Um,
so yeah,
nutrition,
science is in bad shape and I,
and it,
it changed my,
it's changed my faith in expert advice.
Maybe that's the bottom line.
I really don't trust expert advice because I see the way it is manipulated by
financial interests and professional interests and intellectual conflicts of
interest and,
and so,
you know,
even little tiny things like anything,
a warning label on a bottle,
like,
you know,
careful of this plastic or this or that.
I'm like,
I don't believe anything unless I go back to their original science and read it
all myself,
which I can never do.
I just don't trust anything anymore.
That's not a good place to be.
It isn't.
I need to spend.